字幕: Chie Kosuga
校正: Ayana Ishiyama
（拍手）
こんにちは
ありがとうございます
You and I やりたかったです 私も
楽しそうなエクササイズなさってて
The story that's called "Me"
「私」という物語
私の You and I は家族から始まりました
わがままで暴力的な父と
日々心身ともにボロボロになりながら奮闘する母
ムコ多糖症ハンター症候群という
難病を抱えた弟と
私の ４人家族でした
果たして「普通」とは 何であるかはさておき
私は幼少期 自分の家庭が普通でないとは
考えたことが一度もありませんでした
お母さんというのは 「お母さん」
という生き物だと思っていたし
弟というのはお母さんといつも
入院しているものだと思っていました
幼少期の私は 子どもであるがゆえに
守りたいものを守るすべがなく
母に向かって椅子を振り上げる父に
泣いてすがることで精いっぱい
病気のせいで知的 身体的ともに
後退していく弟を
心から愛することで精いっぱいでした
私が小学校３年生になった年
弟の賢治が新入学生となりました
当時 同じ学校の普通学級と特殊学級に
兄弟が一緒に通うという前例がなくて
それはいろいろなリスクを考慮すると
普通では ほぼ考えられないことだったようです
そんな大人たちの配慮があったとは知らずに
子どもだった私は
「絶対に賢治と同じ学校に行きたい」と
言い張ったのを覚えています
「普通」 「一般的」 という概念から
外れるということは
特別であるということです
私はこのときから 「個性」という言葉を
大切にするようになりました
そんな中 賢治の病名が発覚して
余命宣告がなされました
次第に歩けなくなり 話せなくなり
寝たきりになり 自発呼吸ができなくなり
やがて数年後には 命がなくなるでしょう
ただ ひとつだけ
寿命を延ばせるかもしれない方法があります
骨髄移植です
と 私たち家族は 医師から告げられました
血液には型というものがあり
移植対象者とドナーの
血液の型が一致しないと
拒絶反応がおこるため 施術ができません
極力 拒絶反応の起こらないような
型のぴったりと合うドナーを見つけるというのは
なかなか困難なことで
賢治の周りで唯一
最適のドナーとなれる可能性があったのは
私だけでした
そして幸運にも 私たち姉弟の血液の型は
ぴったりと一致しました
９歳だった私に母は
最終的に手術を受けるかどうか
という判断を委ねました
病気だった弟だけではなくて
健康な私の命までも危険にさらすようで
母の中ではそういった意味での
とまどいもあったようですが
当事者の私は 絶対に自分が賢治を
守ってみせるという気持ちで燃えていました
小学生になってもなお
大切なもの 家族を 守るすべを見つけられずに
もどかしくてどうしようもなく思っていた私が
はじめて託されたのは
弟を 弟の命を 救うために
自分の命を懸けたミッションでした
そしてそれは同時に 賢治が私に
私自身が自分の価値を認める
チャンスというものを
くれたのかもしれないと 私は思っています
そしてドナーになることを決断した私は
事前に入院することになりまして
そこで病室を共にしたのは
それぞれが重い病気を抱えた
女の子たちでした
私の左向かいのベッドだった女の子は
小学校２年生
私のひとつ年下だったんですけれども
私と同じ小学校３年生の
国語の教科書を広げて勉強していました
「まだ２年生なのに
なんで３年生の勉強してるの？」と聞くと
「またいつ具合が悪くなって
勉強できなくなっちゃうかわかんないから
できるうちにやっておかないと
ついていけなくなっちゃうんだよね」
と言っていました
私はそのとき ただただ
偉いなと思うばかりでした
のちに その子が３年生になることは
なかったと知って
それまで当たり前だと思っていた
小学校２年生が翌年になれば
小学校３年生になるということ
そんな当たり前のことが
本当は 当たり前ではないということを知って
それまで私の中にあったその概念は
根本から覆されました
毎日学校に行けることや
好きなものを食べられること
外で遊べることや
毎日自分のベッドで眠れること
改めて考えたこともない何気ない日常も
本当は当たり前ではなくて
与えられた幸せなのだということを
目の当たりにしました
せっかく与えてもらった健康体
私にしかできない生き方をしないと
もったいないと考え始めたのも
このときの入院がきっかけです
私の今の生き方を決めた 運命の経験でした
手術を終えて
背中にあいた６つの穴の痛みよりも
大きな達成感と
これで賢治が助かるという
安堵の気持ちを胸に
未来への道を がむしゃらに歩き始めました
そして私が出会い 魅了されたのが
ミュージカルでした
そもそも私とミュージカルを
引き合わせたのは母でした
そしてなぜ母が私に
ミュージカルを与えたのかという
きっかけとなった話は
私がまだ２歳だったころに遡ります
10ヶ月を超えたころから
おしゃべりが大好きな赤ちゃんだった私は
２歳の頃にどハマりしたものがあります
実写吹き替え版の
『不思議の国のアリス』でした
２時間少々の映画ですが
ビデオテープが擦り切れるほど
文字どおり擦り切れるほど 当時は何度も鑑賞して
アリスのセリフを丸暗記
どこへ行ってもアリスになりきりで
一日中セリフを話していたそうです
そのときの記憶を鍵に
お芝居ありき 音楽ありきのミュージカルを
優香に与えてみようと母は考えたようです
こちらの絵画ですけれども
弟の賢治の絵です 作品です
絵画の世界と弟を 引き合わせたのも母でした
何でもぽいっと投げてしまう癖があった賢治に
絵の具をたっぷり含んだ筆を持たせて
和紙を目の前に広げました
そして重なり合った色は 調和し
何ともいえない 幻想的な芸術作品となりました
描き始めた当初から比べて格段に
知的にも身体的にも衰えた賢治は
今では歩くことも話すこともできなくなり
24時間介護が必要な身となってから
もう何年もの時が経過しています
それでも彼は手を使い 指を使い
立派な画家として 私たちに夢や希望や
そして癒しを与え続けてくれています
そうしてミュージカルと出会った私は
そこでソプラノ歌手の恩師と出会いました
歌唱を指導してくれた先生は とても魅力的で
まだ早すぎると仰る先生に頼み込んで
弟子入りをさせていただきました
まだそのくらいの歳ですと 10歳 9歳ですと
声帯が成長しきっていない ということがありまして
通常 若くてもその歳では
恩師は 生徒を取っていなかったんですね
それで私が唯一
恩師の講師人生の中で
本格的にその歳で声楽を習い始めたという
ただ一人の生徒だったようです
そんな恩師も今年に入って亡くなりました
先生と出会っていなければ
今の私はいませんでした
運命とも奇跡ともいえる
先生との出会いを胸に
本格的にミュージカルを勉強すべく
高校生になった私は
イギリスの芸術学校への受験を 決断しました
そしてそのミュージカル科に
合格が決まったちょうどその頃
両親の離婚が決まりました
父からの親権放棄などもあった現実の中で
私が実際に渡英できたのは 母をはじめ
母方の祖父母と 弟 家族みんなからの
応援と支援があったからです
当時 なんの保証もない
自分の未来のために
母に弟の介護のすべてを任せて
日本を離れていって 本当にいいものかと
すごく悩みましたが
目先の苦労を分け合うよりも もっと先を見据えて
挑戦をしてきてほしいという 母の後押しがあって
渡英を決断しました
幸運なことに高校側が
私の歌唱技術を認めてくれて
奨学金をいただきながら
イギリスでの生活はスタートしました
イギリスで生活した７年間の中では
過酷なことも山ほどありましたが
それに勝るほどの楽しいことや嬉しいことを
たくさん経験しました
そして大学卒業の年 2011年
友人からちょうど勧められていたのが
ミス・ユニバース・ジャパンでした
私の知っている 違う文化の２つの故郷
違っていていいところがたくさんありました
「私だからこそ発信できること」をモットーに
挑戦することを決めました
そしてトレーニングを経たのち
北海道代表決定戦の前日
母から聞かされたのは
とても複雑な事実でした
父の死です
49歳でした
家族を捨てて うちを出て行ってから
一度も会うどころか連絡を取ることなく
８年近くが経過していました
私の人生においての
決断という名の試練だったのかもしれません
父に馬鹿にされ続けた自分の
キャリアにおいてのステージを取るか
肉親である父の葬儀を取るか
次の日私は
本選のステージに立っていました
既に父には 新しい家族がいたことへの
配慮も大きくはありましたが
今の自分 その時の自分ができること
自分が前へ進むために
やるべきことを考えた結果 出した答えです
未だにその決断が
正しかったかどうかはわかりません
ただ 決断というのは
正しいかどうかではなくて
自分が責任を持てるかどうかでするべきことだと
私は考えています
私が心から賢治を 愛しているように
これまで障がいが悪いことだと考えたことは
一度もありません
賢治が乗り越えている痛みや辛さは
苦難という言葉では表現しがたいほど
壮絶なものです
できることであれば 自分が大切に想う人が
そのように苦しむ姿というのは
見たくはないですけれど
賢治が私に教えてくれた 生きることへの感動は
かけがえのないものです
障がい者だから 健常者だから
男性だから 女性だから
子どもだから 大人だから
という価値観ではない
私の原点は そこから始まりました
今回 私が歌手や女優としてではなくて
渡邊優香というひとりの人間として
みなさまの前で自分を語ることは
はじめてのことです
人はみんな いろいろな
バックグラウンドを背負って
日々懸命に生きています
みなさまご一緒に
自分の「当たり前」という概念が
無意識に周りの人たちを傷つけていないか
いま一度 考えてみませんか
必ずしも障がいがあるから 不幸なわけではない
必ずしも 年頃の女性だから
結婚して子どもが産めるわけではない
幸せそうに見えるから
お父さんが立派なわけではないし
血がつながっているから 分かり合えるわけではない
それぞれが 人生を生きるうえで
「当たり前」や「一般的」といった
概念を取り払ったなら
それが思いやりに発展して
素敵な You and I に繋がっていく
そのように私は考えています
家族一丸となるどころか
一心同体で生きてこなければ
突き進んではこられなかった
母と賢治と私の３人家族ですが
時を経て それもまた
形を変えるときが来ています
本来 人はみんなそうであるように
それぞれの人生を
それぞれの決断によって
縛り 縛られることなく 自由に生きることを
時がやっと 許してくれているように
私は感じています
それぞれの幸せに挑戦するうえで
失敗してもいい
ただただ時を満喫して
疲れたり傷ついたら 羽を休められる場所が家族
安心できる場所が家族
そんな家族になっていけたらいいなと
私は思っています
そして私はこれからも 私だからこそ歩める人生を
200％全力で 生きていきたいと思っています
本日はみなさまとの新しい You and I
素敵な出会いをいただけましたことを
心より嬉しく思っております
最後に 私の声の四重唱と
賢治の絵画を
感謝の気持ちとともにお送りいたします
みなさま ご清聴ありがとうございました
『アメージング・グレース』を心より
みなさまにプレゼントしたいと思います
みなさまのこれからが 幸せでありますように
（音楽）
ありがとうございました
（拍手）
Thank you very much.